8 watts est extrêmement jalouse c'est
vrai ah ouais alors tenez par exemple
games technique mais tu dis tu demandes
à ton mari de paris avec d'autres filles
oui c'est vrai n'a pas le droit de le
toucher
je ne peux pas je supportais pas tu
expliques à ton mari aussi te dit
explique donc comme tu l'as dit déjà
qu'il a une meilleure amie et que ça me
tracasse un peu oui c'est vrai je peux
me parle de tout ça de ma vie en vrai
vrai service à tenir vraiment qu'ils les
meilleurs amis n'ont aucun souci non
samedi mais c'est vrai un peu et parce
que sam à coeur c'est bizarre que le
rouge surtout quand huawei sacrant ya
bleus ya jaune et choisies rouge le
coeur de l'amour la peur de l'amour tu
penses qu'un n'ya rien alors je vois tu
sais je sais lien encore oui bonsoir
c'est à quel sujet elle s'est calmé la
colère des sourires dans les loges oui a
dit que je lui avais offert une veste
même d'accord c'est que je reçois plein
d'habits gratuit wine & shueisha fait
conseils qu'on n'est pas ça la jalousie
envie de faire un petit tour de table
sur la jalousie un article qui dit que
plus d'un français sur cinq a déjà
regardé le portable ou l'ordinateur de
son conjoint en cachette m'a bien sûr
qu'il a déjà fait si la greffe est bravo
vous avez découvert détruit en bois
m'est arrivé un truc à lui voit rien
arriver une chose affreuse que je crois
à personne et quelques années j'étais
avec une de mes ex femme et on était en
train de se séparer ça allait pas trahir
comme d'habitude quoi là et donc elle
est partie en vacances en moi et le
portable est tombé dans le dans l'eau
donc il s'est arrêté il était cassé et
quand elle est revenue le portable a
séché et j'ai pu le rallumer non et là
je suis tombé sur des mois de cotisation
avec un autre jeu vous nommez la blague
à part ça fait un mal de chien sans
michel trama bâtard
les traits du roi c'est vrai quand il a
tout lu tout l'été tous les mois et des
mois
et à chaque fois tu vois la date unique
à wes affreux c'est la première réaction
quand il m'a franchement je me suis mis
à pleurer
non c'était bien celui-là des tout
petits au lieu de s'arrêter non on va
toujours plus loin et on continue on va
jusqu'au bout c'est aurait été alors
qu'est ce que tu as dis à ta meuf à ce
que tu as dit on peut se parler de
minutes non mais je suis pas j'étais
assez j'ai dû l'appeler dire bravo je
réagis pas le temps c'est normal non
mais non même si j'ai appris que j'ai
volé sur le sur le conjoint moi je sais
vous avez fait pipi dans sa bouche oui
dans sa salle et je me suis dans sa
vodka sa vodka kabila votre vieux c'est
un peu un peu jaune
ouais comme boat people baby et donc
j'ai mis au congélateur
au bout d'un moment j'ai pas bien jaugé
en fait l'eau et paraît que c'est fin
d'une piste
[Applaudissements]
gas in situ c'est tout bon exactement
comme benjamin aurait de toute façon
quand on chez moi c'est une réunion de
coke
[Rires]
alors les cocus alors que la loi accorde
droit direct quand on checke le portable
généralement c'est déjà trop tard parce
qu'on a un doute c'est effectivement là
j'ai bien vu je vous dire quand on
cherche on trouve toujours
c'est le problème est content s'achève
au témoignage pour votre épouse jolie
quand on cherche on trouve toujours à
noah papa groove et cherchez vous allez
forcément trouver un bail mais bordeaux
je suis blanc comme neige mais voilà
mais si vous voulez voilà mais je vous
dis alors flou après après moi j'ai rien
dit voilà j'ai laissé le portable non je
suis rentré à paris
et là j'ai checké j'ai piraté sa boîte
mail non j'ai cru que les mails comment
t'as fait je trouve les mots de passe
les machins sur sa boîte mail et là j'ai
fait comme benjamin j'ai tout lu assez
alors à quelle heure on commenté et je
suis là dessus après leur entrée j'ai
rien dis toujours je t'invite en
week-end meiway tous les deux et dix y
être qu'on s'explique je les noyés avec
une parka quand même dans les
destinations tu seras vous passez en
arcade où s'asseoir pour qu'il fasse
entrer l'accusé l'ambition d'aller alors
dans une hausse que tu ne fais pas les
instruments s'expliquer pendant tout le
week-end pour savoir si c'était sérieux
ou pas et c'était sérieux quoi renvoyer
bravo christophe car c'est bien classés
franchement ça non parce qu'il a il a eu
une discussion où à la fin du week-end
bravo christophe tu la connais
c'est ça qu'il faut faire c'est vannes
c'est beau un bras vol tous les mecs qui
n'ont garde faune et christophe carrière
je voudrais si pacy qui a dit regardez
moi j'ai des traits vous bat marie
d'agadez sur votre militaire oui j'avais
cela j'avais installé sur mon le
téléphone de ma copine de l'époque un
logiciel espion
s'ils me coûtait une fortune ça me
coûtait presque 100 euros par mois non
donc j'ai vraiment que j'étais jaloux
j'étais fume acheté en mode vénère de
ouf la même justice qui me permettait
dès qu'elle recevait un appel un texte
où n'importe quoi j'avais une alerte sur
mon téléphone la personne la plaie j'ai
émis les alertes ont fait ça sans
ordinateur c'est ça existe toujours mais
ça marche pas sur les apple ça marche
que sur la marque concurrente et donc
des carreaux sur un coup de fil de
ladite personne même si j'étais au
travail ça sonnait chez moi ça sonnait
et j'écoutais et j'entendais toute la
conversation
c'est aux origines enregistre
automatiquement sur mon ordinateur et je
ne peux rien l'autre coup il encore sur
touche pas à mon poste mais mieux que ça
avec ce logiciel jeu pouvait à tout
moment déclencher le micro ton téléphone
c'est alors à tout moment je peux
entendre ce qui se passait autour d'elle
arrive déclencher une photo cl sont avez
vous fait ça existe bien sûr mais comme
le téléphone souvent comme ça il faut le
logiciel 100 euros par mois vous avez
pris son partage
il faut avoir le mot de passe ce sont
des vols ça registre et qui après est
complètement invisible même si elle
l'emmène chez un réparateur ça ne se
voit pas si sûr ça coûte très cher mais
j'arrive au bout et on arrête parce
qu'on n'a plus d'eau appelée argent mais
on découvre des choses
ça y est tu savais ça tout est faudrait
qu'elle prenait sur son téléphone je les
avais sûrement toutes les photos il est
trop fier toutes les photos toutes
on peut être surpris je vous ai reconnu
sur certaines plus parle alors comme
benjamin qui reçoit les sm assure son
four prend ces mesures en train de
prendre en train de faire une quiche
elle reçoit j'ai envie de toi achetez
vous et qu'elle a acheté un frigo
connecter avec avec un écran soit au
dessus ouais faut consulter alors roger
d'actrice quoi vous en quoi le net et ne
paient pas ça je veux le dire très
gentiment que j'étais avec mon camarade
de l'époque un jeune garçon par garçon
très bon rythme et comment 1
c'est quoi son prénom appelons le arthur
pour l'histoire il embrasse justement et
y ont arrêté un an un an et demi et j'ai
jamais rencontré quelqu'un que je
trouvais très joli et comme je voulais
pas le tromper parce que je suis honnête
je propose à mon ami à 3 bat était là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
de faire connaissance ouais je montre la
photo à mon ami qui me dira non pas trop
mon genre non je ne sens pas je ne sois
pas très bien ce que me permettre je
leur mets dans ma culotte on n'en parle
plus merci terminée et un jour qu'il
n'est pas là sur l'ipad passons le
téléphone sonne ipad arrive le truc
sommes arrivés à un texto il n'y a pas
de code sur les pattes j'ouvre et qu'est
ce que je vois des deux est en train de
ski faire ensemble et dans le week-end
ils l'avaient kent
non parce que c'est pas une honte alors
ses patrons que les gens j'étais honnête
j'ai ouvert mon coeur j'ai tout ouvert
[Rires]
vous entendez le gars était en porte
ouverte
un homme et c'est vrai vous c'est fou
c'est moche voilà je vous le dis c'est
moche merci merci merci de soutien de
tous les camarades oui bon on vous
soutient merci merci merci